bye
uh
all right great
[Music]
and we're all set all right good evening
everybody it is just about six o'clock
we are here at the rockingham county
superior court in brentwood new
hampshire this is a public input session
for the new hampshire
special committee on redistricting of
the house of representatives and before
we get going this is
official court business i'm going to ask
if people would rise and join me in a
pleasure league
[Music]
thank you everyone
and thank you
for those of you here with us tonight
for attending this community input
session um this is being audio and video
recorded to be subsequently placed
online and made publicly available i
understand it is also being live
streamed which you can access from the
new hampshire house of representative
website
um as you can see this is not a typical
house or senate meeting this is a joint
meeting not all members of each
committee are present
but before we begin introductions i
would like to say as i mentioned we are
here at the brentwood county superior
courthouse we are here with the
permission of the superior court and um
others involved in the administration of
this court in the ownership of the
building and i'm not sure whether in
rockingham if that includes the county
commissioners or not but they're
certainly aware please understand that
this has that the superior court or the
court system of new hampshire and i'm
referring to this as the superior court
this is the family court and the
superior court for brentwood for
rockingham county
but the courts have nothing to do with
this process
they don't know what we're talking about
i don't know that they have any idea
that this meeting is actually really
occurring outside of the administration
office they have been very accommodating
to us to allow us to use this it has
good parking and is fairly central for
rockingham county so we thank the court
system of new hampshire for letting us
use this facility but again they have
absolutely nothing to do
with the process and have had no input
whatsoever in regards to the process
itself
i have a former judge here you know i
wanted to also make sure i did that
all right so the first thing i want to
do is let you know who we have here
tonight as i said we have the senate and
the house the senate is conducting its
own hearing the house is conducting a
hearing and with us is senator gray who
is chair of the senate committee on
redistricting and so i'd like to
recognize senator gray and ask him to
introduce the senate members with us
tonight well thank you very much uh just
a couple of um housekeeping notes
uh senate rules don't allow cheering
booing uh that kind of things that's
inappropriate for
the venue that we're in
um the maps that you saw in the big post
is outside
again
the way we take testimony is things that
we can get his hand out so we do have
handouts i believe that the house
committee got those last week that the
senator's got today
so taking care of those and today what
we have is uh senator susie and senator
bertson if you want to say anything
okay so uh thank you all for coming
thank you senator gray and thank you
senators for joining us uh my name is
barbara griffin i'm a representative
from the town of goffstown and i'm going
up to my left are members of the house
of representatives special committee on
redistricting and i'm going to
ask them to introduce themselves
starting with representative turcotte to
my left
thank you madam chair representative
from the town of barrington stratfor
district four i serve on this committee
is
also the finance committee labor
committee and
a senior advisor in the house majority
office
good evening my name is wayne mcdonald i
live here in rockingham county i
represent district 5 which is the town
of londonderry
i also serve as vice chairman of the
election law committee in the house on
being on this committee
hi good evening my name is bob lynn i'm
a representative from windham uh that's
rob kansas seven and i serve on the
finance committee uh
division
good evening i'm paul bergeron
thank you
i'm paul bertrand representing
hillsborough district 29 which is
national war ii
and in addition to serving on this
committee i serve over selection
good evening i'm marjorie smith i
represent durham and nagari in stratford
county
and i serve on the
house judiciary committee in addition to
this committee
evening thank you for coming my name is
lucy webber uh
i represent uh cheshire district one
which is the connecticut river town from
coal west north chesterfield and um
kingsdale so i'm very glad to come over
to the other side of the stadium
and i also serve on the health human
services military if there's many
environmental chair alone and we have
covered this before i'm going to say
that i'm still very saddened that we do
not have remote participation for either
committee members or members of the
world
hi i'm connie lane i'm from ward 2 in
concord and i'm on the house election
law committee as well assistant
and i think you've been joined by
another center i am aware of that thank
you representatives um senator gray did
you want to introduce the latest entry
to our panel senator rebecca
perkins boca has just arrived yes hi
everyone i'm senator rebecca spoka i
represent district 21 which is
portsmouth durham new market in the
surrounding towns nice to see everyone
thank you and with that we're going to
begin to hear from you in regards to the
redistricting process that we are
undertaking in the house uh the number
of people have signed up there should
still be a sign up sheet outside i'm
going to go through this list in order
and then we'll get the sheet with the
second page of people who have signed up
to speak if you have written testimony
you can either pass it over to christina
dyer who's our support staff with us
tonight or on the right to
representative lane and we'll make sure
that it gets to all members and into the
file
and when you come up to speak i'm going
to ask that you come
to the guys right there with the
microphone and
you'll be standing right where the
lawyers do in connection with court so
uh
welcome to the courtroom six of the
secure report so the first person to
sign up is jane armstrong from exeter
good evening
my name is
jane armstrong
and i'm a resident of exeter here in
rockingham county
i'm concerned about a fair non-partisan
and transparent redistricting process
this evening however i would like to
speak to just one piece of the process
but an important one
this topic is ensuring that every
eligible town has its own district
in new hampshire we're very proud of our
unique
legislature of 400 representatives we
talk about how it enables us to meet our
representatives in our daily lives
shopping at transfer stations and town
events
this is why in 2006
we voted to pass the constitutional
amendment
which says
that when a town population
is within a reasonable deviation from
the ideal population
which this year 2020 is 3444
that town shall have his representative
shall have its own district
so now giving towns of 3444
their own representative is internal in
our constitution
here in rockingham county
14 that's 14
towns were eligible in 2010 for their
own district
house district
with a 2010
number of 3192
but they were denying it
these include
atkinson
auburn
cambia
chester
deerfield
greenland
kingston hampstead newmarket
nottingham plaistow
rye
sandown
and seabrook
i'm asking you to give these towns and
others in the state
what the new hampshire constitution
guarantees them
they deserve to have representatives who
have been in town
representatives who know the people
and the issues
i also wonder why
if it was so hard in 2010
why has nothing been done to make the
legislative and constitutional changes
to fix this problem
the legislature has had 10 years
i suspect
that it's possible there are some who
don't want to fix it
i understand that the math makes it hard
to get every eligible town its own
district
but surely you can make the effort to
get these towns the representative
station they deserve and are
entitled to receive
thank you
i said i didn't have written testimony
feel free to give it to us and we'll
make sure that a copy gets okay
just put right into it
for those that just came in i'm senator
gray i'm the chair
of the senate portion of this
clapping
booing
or not appropriate in this hearing
okay so i appreciate your cooperation
stephen bourne
welcome
thank you see you in the
morning this is from our bill of rights
ratified in 1798 it's article 10.
government being instituted for the
common benefit protection and security
of the whole community
and not for the private interest
surrounding any one man family or class
of men therefore whenever the ends of
government are perverted
and public liberty manifestly endangered
all other means of redress are
ineffectual the people may and right
ought to reform the old or establish a
new government the doctrine of
non-resistance against arbitrary power
and oppression is absurd slavish and
destructive the good the happiness of
mankind so i make sure you all know that
um so
i just want to talk about a couple of
the phrases in here
all right when all other means of
redress are ineffectual that means we
need to put in the effort
to try to make things right
and to get the government to represent
the people so the last 20 years we've
lived under
gerrymandering and by the way it is gary
it's named dr albert gary and that's how
you pronounce his name
and
we need to try to fix that now
a hundred dollars a year is not much so
we greatly appreciate the time to drive
around to all the different counties and
listen to people and it's an incredible
first step it's the right thing to do to
listen to people and understand what we
think is broken all right but the most
important step is the second step
and that comes once you start coming up
with a first proposal
to make sure that people have the time
to look at it and make sure there's not
even the slightest suspicion of any
gerrymandering
as you just heard
rye is one of the 74 towns that put
forth petition
or motion
saying that we want our town leaders to
let the new hampshire general court know
that we expect an open and transparent
process with no gerrymandering now i
don't know i think you've heard from the
town leaders abroad
saying that that's what the people voted
for
i don't see them here
i just spoke to representative she
hasn't heard from them
so it's hard we're trying we're trying
to get through that this is
gary mandering does not want the people
of new hampshire at least the 74 people
that went through the effort of getting
that warrant article passed on and by
the way selected to support it and ryan
so what's the second part i wanted to
talk about was
amulet of any one man family or class of
men now emulate i had to look it up the
first time i read this it means to
benefit and i think we can agree that
the class of men is a political party
now i've been reaching out to bill
gardner and dave scanlon they haven't
told me but maybe they'll tell you
how much does the state pay for the two
primaries excuse me the primaries every
two years for the parties
you should know that number because it's
our money
all right also you need to look at what
the towns and cities spend on that
election every two years
on top of that our town we voted one of
the schools they closed the other school
so it's a lost state of education it's a
big investment that the people in new
hampshire are paying for and when it's
benefiting a class of men or the
political party it's going against our
constitution and we just heard from the
previous speaker rye is also one of
those towns um the census says we've got
5 400
people we've had that for a while
november we had over 6 000 people who
voted a lot of those were the 20 year
olds that moved back i don't think it
was quite 600
but
with the
0.7
miles on route 1 with almost every
parcel being developed the next few
years will soon be at the 6800 to have
two reps we don't even have one
all right we share one with newcastle
now newcastle's rebecca can probably
tell you here's the santa cable perkins
that
parking style that that newcastle
probably is a lot more in common with
the southern end of portsmouth
all right
we probably have more in common with
northampton but northampton's extra
people got thrown in one of those
fertility districts with four or five
other districts so there's another
example that can be happening
now
i don't really like either party to be
honest with you i spend a lot of my time
trying to fix
democracy if you look around
i don't see a lot of younger people here
do you
you ever wonder why
why they don't participate why they
don't get involved
now i think a good example is i don't
know
um if any 20 something's ever said okay
boomer do you
do you know what really if you ever talk
to them and ask them what that really is
about
mr bourne just keep in mind we have a
number of people signed up to speak
tonight and this is about the
redistricting process
so what they mean by that is that
when we're talking down at them and
looking back at us and saying
who are you to tell me what to do
forget about climate change look at
democracy it's a mess
you guys have made a mockery of it it's
a money-driven process the the political
the
party primaries 30 somebody could win
with 30 of the votes 70 percent of the
people will prep for someone else we
have to pick between the two people and
then we've got gary mandarin right and
and no wonder why they they're checked
out they don't want people now is our
opportunity
to make some difference it took a long
time for everything to get this messed
up but we can make you have the
opportunity now to put things in the
right direction
all right if the job's done right and
what the citizens want there won't be a
single sniff iota of gerrymandering that
should be the goal you should look at
those maps and no one should question or
even doubt that there's any
garrymandering that happened to
hampshire that's what the people want
that's a step to take to try to make our
democracy work better thank you
thank you thank you we are gonna
i am gonna
they're clapping we've made two
announcements now
um
we ask that everybody be respectful of
everyone who speaks and that means
reacting the same and we ask you to be
with respectful silence having
considered the comments of everyone um
we have had another representative join
us since uh we began taking cover
comment representative if you could
introduce yourself
thank you madam chair um representative
israel piedra representing hillsborough
district 9. thank you
thank you
thank you and next up we have bonnie
cameron
hi it's bernie and cameron oh sorry so
thank you for clarifying yes sir
so i want to address something that can
happen and does happen when towns
are not allowed to have their own
district and their own state
representative
i've lived in deerfield since 1972
up until
up until 2002
deerfield had its own house district and
its own state representative
he or she was a resident of deerfield
he knew deerfield well
he understood
the issues that were affecting our town
and he was an active contributor to the
community
he was well respected
and different
he was chosen by the people of deerfield
to be their representative
that's the way it always had been
that is no longer the case
since 2002
our state representatives have been
chosen by the majorities in our
multi-district
multi-town district
not necessarily by a majority of
deerfield residents
for example
we have had individuals run repeatedly
for deerfield town offices
such as school board
select board
and each time
these individuals have lost
those elections
they are well known in town and they are
not elected to these positions
and yet these same individuals go on to
become our state representatives
why
because they are not known in the other
towns in our district
they are elected based sold on their
party
rather than their accomplishments or
their integrity
this is not right
and this is what deerfield is facing now
it is time to return to our town of
deerfield our constitutional right to
have our own single district
and a state representative that is
chosen by our residents
thank you thank you
next we have fred mcgarrett
[Music]
madam chair members of the committee
my name is uh fred mcgarry and i'm a
member of the deerfield board of
selectmen the board has authorized me to
speak tonight
on his behalf to the special committee
on redistricting
at the annual town meeting
election held
this year uh was delayed to june
the town voted
477 to 233 urging the legislature to
ensure fair and effective representation
of new hampshire voters
and to minimize multi-seat districts
the new hampshire constitution part 2
article 11 states
when the population of any town or ward
according to the latest federal census
is within a reasonable deviation
from the ideal population for
one or more representative seats the
town of ward shall have its own district
of one or more representative seats
the 2020 population of nuclear field was
eight hundred and 4850
well in excess
of the population requirement of three
thousand four hundred and forty-five
which i think i got wrong three hundred
thousand four hundred forty four
for each representative in new hampshire
the deerfield board of selectmen
received petitions from over 80 voters
calling
for the board to advocate for
deanfield's own representative district
each member of the committee has a
packet with a copy of those petitions
after the august second meeting of the
board of slack and the board voted
unanimously to merge the special
committee on redistricting to establish
a representative district exclusive to
deerfield
the deerfield voter selection concurs
with the vote at the annual meeting and
the petitions it received and urged the
redistricting committee to establish a
representative district specific to dear
field
thank you for this opportunity to
provide my testimony like to thank the
committee for holding this public
hearing in providing new hampshire
residents citizens the opportunity to
offer input into the redistricting
process thank you
next for junior clifford please
madam chair honourable members of the
house of representatives and the senate
um thank you for um holding this session
um my name is virginia clifford and i
live in candia
and we don't have anyone in the house
from kenya
and so
people so far are speaking to the same
issue that i have a concern for um i
vote for four people
um
we
we select three people from district two
and we
vote for and we vote for one person from
district 32.
none of them
of the four three live in deerfield and
one lives and not encampment so as other
speakers have um already stated um i
think it would be very beneficial to
candia to have a representative um in
the house of representatives
and and reflecting on this i guess just
one
comment i would make um sort of from my
own point of view and maybe an editorial
perspective is
we have too much partisanship and if i
were to vote from someone from canadia i
wouldn't really be considering
and maybe i should but is this person a
republican or a democrat i would be
saying
has this person been a selectmen has
this person worked at the polls
what has this person done to contribute
to this
responsibility of the town
so again um i really would appreciate
having a representative for the town of
candia and we have almost 4 000 people
now we're just shy
thank you very much
thank you
june february from exeter
well
i've lived in exeter which is part of
senate district 23 for more than seven
years i'm testifying at this hearing
because i feel that senator script 23
fails to properly represent me due to a
partisan advantage for republicans in my
district this scary mandarin is subtle
but significant
since we are in the process of
redistricting i'd like to see the new
legislative lines
drawn in a non-partisan way instead of
continuing to favor republicans
the process that i've noticed goes like
this
my district has been designed so that
the number of democrats in the district
are just enough to almost but not quite
win elections
as a result for instance in the 2020
election the large number of democratic
votes including my own have been
essentially wasted because our votes
have not been converted into seats
in a 2016 article
new hampshire public radio describes
their election research when one party
consistently loses by thin margins an
efficiency gap that calculates wasted
votes develops
diluting the democratic votes this way
makes my districts and others less
competitive
my voice and those of other democrats
have not been represented and conquered
by the republicans who have been elected
in the past
when this process happens across many
districts the partisan disadvantages for
democrats multiplies resulting in huge
numbers of democrats losing proper
representation in concord
now is the time to write this sprawn
it is the time to redistrict in a
non-partisan way
thank you
representative joe gupta
thank you madam chair senators
uh i'd like to i'm uh
a state bro state rep in uh district 13
and i'm also a selectmen in hampstead
and just like the uh just a little input
from uh as far as
the town of hampton is concerned we are
uh in a district with kingston
and we have four reps
and we bend over backwards as a
community
to make sure that we can have two
from
kingston and two from
hampstead and
so
even though
both towns have increased in population
we're all pushing 9000 each
uh and uh
that may give you some hot cheddar when
you start to uh
set up the districts but
i just like and then i would also like
to say that in my opinion and i've i
served on this committee back in the 90s
and it was done a little bit different i
like to complement the commission took
for the openness
of the process now the
the uh going to each one of the counties
i think that's great the uh uh using the
uh
the uh where will all we have to get our
message across is great
uh so all those things are good and i
think that's important because today
we're talking about transfer
[Music]
being
open and above when we're doing our
business and i suggest that
that's probably the most important thing
we have to concern ourselves with every
10 years that is that we're transparent
and i would suggest to you
that because of the process
uh it's very difficult to be more
transparent than you already are
but i think that every effort should be
made to be transparent
uh the other thing i think is a concern
i think you're set up to fail
the guidelines and the goals that you
have in redistricting sets you up in the
house side to fail
you you cannot do your job
without failing some communities it's
just the way it is we talked about
gerrymandering
now that's a nice word it came from
massachusetts where i come from
originally
but what is german gerrymandering
assumes
that you're making
decisions based on strictly politics and
i submit to you that that's not the case
i know most of the members on this
committee and i know that there's enough
strong votes on both sides
that make sure that
the
real
gerrymandering is never done
but
it
the impression is that it's
gerrymandering because of the rules and
regulations you have
and i would suggest that unless you
change those rules
that's going to continue
and i suggest to you also that
in order to make the
system more transparent and more
comfortable
that we take a real hard look at what's
being proposed in many
uh areas and that is that we change the
makeup
of your commission
unless we change the
nature of your commission
or change the rules and the rules are
harder to change
i think we're going to continue to do
this and i commend you for doing the job
with the uh
chance that you it's just going to be
impossible for you to
make everybody
happy and i uh
hope that if uh if there's anything you
can do
uh particularly in supporting because i
think it's bipartisan
supporting the concept that we change
the commission
that we have an equal republican the
equal democrat
uh and probably with an unequal uh
citizen participation that's being
advocated that that's the answer to
solve some of the problems we're done
tonight thank you
thank you next signed up i have chris
muns from hampton
madam chairman and members of the
committee
my name is chris muns i served as a
state representative representing
hampton between
2012 and 2014.
i was also a candidate for the state
senate in district 24.
i know what a commitment of time and
energy uh this is for you and i'd like
to thank you all for your service
there's nothing more central to our
representative democracy than voters
believing the prop process they must
follow to elect their representatives is
transparent and fair
to that end i thank you for the
opportunity you are giving individuals
throughout new hampshire to share their
input with you
i hope the decisions you make will
reflect the input you have received
it is unfortunate however
that given the recent increases in coven
cases across the state you chose not to
provide an option for the public to
testify
remotely i urge you to reconsider that
decision and to add that flexibility to
the remaining listing sessions you have
scheduled
in light of the comments made by the
chairman of the new hampshire republican
party that maps will be manipulated so
as to favor his party
it is essential that you not only
renounce those statements but that you
commit to holding another round of
hearings after the maps are drawn
so that the public has a chance to
provide you with their input and so that
you can demonstrate that the process
used to draw those maps was indeed fair
to give the public enough time to
provide you with meaningful input the
public needs at least 10 days notice of
all future public hearings
the two best litmus tests of whether the
process is fair
will be what you decide to do with our
two congressional districts
and five executive council districts
there have been minimal changes in
population between the existing
congressional districts
and the changes to the maps of those
districts should be very minimal
it will be telling however if you adopt
a map that either bisects manchester or
proposes to move it from congressional
district 1 to congressional district 2.
executive council district 2 is
currently one of the best examples of
gerrymandering anywhere in the country
it and the other executive council
districts need to be
redrawn
so that they better represent
communities of sheer interest and the
partisan balance that exists within the
state
failure to do so will cast doubt on the
whole redistricting process
that same principle grouping communities
together who have shared interests
should guide how senate state senate
districts are drawn
in district 24 for example
newton has more in common with plasto
currently in district 22
than it does with newcastle
which has much more in common with
portsmouth which is currently in
district 21.
you need to end the practice of creating
safe republican and safe democratic
districts
wherever possible every town with more
than 3 500 residents should have at
least one state representative
representative representing just that
town and we should minimize the number
of floateral districts
where a floaterial district is necessary
the principle of grouping communities
with shared interest should be followed
there as well
hampton falls which currently shares
three seats with seabrook has less in
common with seabrook than for example
kensington
and northampton which currently shares a
seat with newington and portsmouth has
less in common with those two towns than
it does greenland or strata
finally as a former state representative
from hampton i would be remiss if i did
not say
that as a that as a town with almost 16
000 people
we should have at least four state
representatives representatives
representing just hampton
thank you again for your time this
evening and thank you for your service
thank you
i also have signed up to speak ken hager
i apologize i think i probably
mispronounced your last name it can be
pronounced a dozen different ways
[Music]
thank you first of all for giving me the
opportunity to speak
i've been sitting back there and my
opening
has probably changed a half a dozen
times
but it always comes back to one thing
this would not be my preferred method of
redistricting i would have an
independent body
made up that i would follow along with
mr guthrie said
of an equal number of democrats and
republicans and
augmented
by a group of citizens because you need
an odd number in order to get a majority
of one side or the other
i don't know any of you except for
representative bergeron
um
i'm going to assume you're all
fair-minded people
but i've been living in rockingham
county for more than 40 years and i know
some reps who are anything but
fair-minded and that's the people i'm
afraid of
we can talk all we want about
the criteria in fact i'm not an expert
i'm not sure there is any expert on
redistricting
because there are so many criteria to go
into it it's like peeling an onion
but the gentleman just spoke before me
about this town having something in
common with that town what does that
mean
shared school district
shared water departments
i don't know what that means
i do know that the worst criteria
is political
based on
party affiliation
and that's what i'm afraid it's gonna
happen here
mr muns talked about i i didn't even
know how bad uh the executive council of
district two was until i started on a
map and i thought
you know when i'm in power that's what's
going to happen so let me just give you
just a little
anecdote
that may or may not have any uh
relevance here
um i used to coach a lot of rec sports
when i was a kid
and soccer especially he always have
trouble getting enough kids to play the
game
so you show up and it's supposed to be
11 and the other team would have nine or
i would have nine he'd have 11.
and the overwhelming majority of the
time
we adjusted our rosters
to play evenly if he had nine i would
play nine
and that's what i'm hoping is going to
happen here just because you're in a
position of power because you're in a
position of majority
doesn't mean you can't be fair
because the table is going to turn
someday and you're going to be on the
losing side
and one game we played
the uh opposite coach decided to play
his 11 against my eighth we got b
and i was coaching 12 year olds at the
time and they were old enough to know
that that wasn't fair
and we played that team later in the
season at even strength we swamped them
and the reason was because my kids
remembered that they hadn't played fair
and it gave them extra motivation
so you democrats republicans whoever is
in the majority particular time when
these decisions are made
has to remember that the
the this it's gonna turn the tide is
gonna turn someday you're not going to
be the position of majority and i just
hope that the opposite side
is fair if you've been fair thank you
thank you
harry katy has signed up to speak
i'm not going to accuse anybody of
gerrymandering
having served on election law when we
had to
divide the state up
and i know i certainly didn't
the
other thing is to
people here they remember it or not
the last
redistricting was done by the corpse
and they joined us
however
they decided i don't know
so
i look at it
that
what i would love to have is every town
represented i realize
we don't
have that in our constitution
we have
up to 400
house members
24 senators
what i do want to see
is it possible a state rep
in in my town for years we had roger
king
of whom one of the previous speakers
followed
and anybody could talk to roger
that's what i want a legislator
i can talk with and have them hear my
point of view see my point of view
and tell me why they don't support me
and i have had that
and i like that
when i was a state rep i represented
nottingham
northwood deerfield pandia
and i made an effort once a month to go
to each town
and talk with the town
nottingham was fantastic we had people
ask us what we would come on sunday
and
vic vic now and i would go over one
sunday a month
and take any question they had on what
was going on in the legislature
other towns we had to depend upon
speaking to these selectmen
i want to thank you all for doing this
job it's a hard job to do because you
always have dissatisfaction
with somebody
but i know what it is to redistrict
when we did it
in 2002
my committee did it
2003.
but when the court did it
we had a real mix-up of towns
and
i have seen
the legislature go from republican to
all democrat to republican
so that
it changes off
and i don't see
people understanding our government
that's what i feel the strongest about
we really need
more education in how new hampshire's
legislature
executive council and governor work
thank you
thank
you gory warnock has also signed up from
hampstead
good evening and thank you uh senators
and representatives for holding this
session tonight so that you can be heard
as mentioned i am from hampstead i'm a
taxpayer a voter and a selector
i'm not here in my role as a selectman
however
i have to agree with my
compatriot mr guthrie although we often
are on opposite sides of the question i
think we do share
a common goal
in that we both feel
that hampstead as with many of the other
communities
deserve their constitutionally
guaranteed right to representation as
someone who
ran for a representative
in the last session
i know how challenging it is to really
master the needs of my own community let
alone
trying to understand the needs of the
communities adjacent
and
while i don't end with the job of our
senators who have several communities i
have to represent
i think we have
really demonstrated the population of
over 8 000
that we don't share a school district
with kingston we don't share any of our
public safety
entities with other communities we are
an entity in and of ourselves with our
own needs
and so i hope that going forward as
representative guthrie mentioned
the tables do turn
and i think it's in
all of our best interests to come up
with a fair process that is transparent
that is
gives notice of at least 10 days of
these public hearings so that the public
is available to participate that does
allow the remote testimony because we
know that there are still folks that are
at risk in attending large gatherings
like these
and
that
you know make the effort to really make
this a public event which i do
appreciate when you mention it will be
live streamed and that will be recorded
as well so
thank you very much for your time
tonight thank you for your comments
signed up to speak is from exeter is
skip variant
thank you madam chair
nice to see some familiar faces from
this table from my past experience
thank you for your work to address the
monumental task
of creating social economic and
political balance within new hampshire
this is a dangerously polarized time for
our state
and you have the opportunity yes you
have the opportunity to address this
fractured status
by creating responsible and fair
electoral districts
in an open and transparent manner
rockingham county has experienced
considerable growth and transformation
in the last decade
with changes in its populations social
economic and political dynamics
in particular i would like to address
the needs of senate district 23 in which
i live
and from which i serve three terms in
the new hampshire house
the current district includes the towns
of exeter and east
to chester in the west
these towns have divergent orientations
either toward the salem i-23 quarter
versus the seacoast of rockingham county
if you could consider a redistricting of
senate
district 23
i propose a plan that would acknowledge
the social and economic realities of
this part of the state
this plan would completely or almost
completely include
three large school districts or saus
which are currently distributed among
four
senate districts
this alternative district would also
include major commercial centers located
in epping and exeter which are
frequented by people in these towns
this alternative plan would take into
account the natural affinities of the
pot of the population
in
everyday life
politically
district 23 has been dominated by
republican voters for
decades this alternative plan by my
estimation
would continue with republican voter
domination
however by judging from the current
house reps in these towns
there would be a slight increase in
democratic voters
thus contributing to a more equitable
political division
what i think also should be a goal of
redistricting
i offer this plan for your consideration
which maintains a stable population size
within the district
as you proceed with your deliberations
in an open and transparent manner as
you've heard from so many people tonight
we hope that there will be time for
public scrutiny
and public comment as well
i acknowledge that you have many many
issues to consider
and
in my plan
yes you have to rob peter to pay paul
and that's going to be a difficult
process for you all
but
i thank you for giving me consider
giving this consideration
thank you
thank you very much
um
for people who didn't hear this
testimony will be online he had a
specific
towns that he proposed to change from
the senate district
jack mccrory
representative
thank you first of all welcome to
rockingham county
um and i thank you for the time that you
spent listening to the citizens of new
hampshire
first of all i'd like to correct a
statement that is made earlier lying you
canceled business chair or state
representative we have two i am one and
kate murray is another so that district
has two representatives
so those watch i have a question and i
think it's important um
if we can get the answer should those
watching live stream
want to send input to this process
what's the process for them to
communicate their concerns or questions
thank you very much i'll address that at
the end i forgot to do it
okay thank you
and then my hope is that public input is
truly considered in establishing fair
districts and therefore i ask that maps
have drawn and shared with the public
with the intent that further public
opinion is allowed
thank you
frank hepburn
would you like to
[Music]
okay
uh
matthew storer
from chester oh
i see my bad handwriting has perceived
me it's uh silver from chester
um
thank you for holding this listening
session and for undertaking the
important work of preparing
a redistricting plan consistent with the
constitution of the laws of new
hampshire to ensure fair and effective
representation for all citizens of
rockhampton county in the state as well
my name is matthew stoker i've lived in
chester for 18 years
and i've been honored to serve our
community on the school boards by the
committee of the trustees of trust funds
on may 15th of this year
the chester town meeting
voters republicans democrats
independents
all the members of the select board
passed unanimously
an article that urged new hampshire
general court to carry out the
redistricting in a fair and transparent
way through public meetings not to favor
a particular political party and to
include communities of interest and to
minimize multi-seat districts
the article furthermore cited the new
hampshire state constitution part 2
article 11 allowing towns of sufficient
population to have their own state
representatives and not share with other
towns
and directed the town to petition the
general court for its own exclusive seat
in the house of representatives
i'd like to speak specifically to why
chester should be provided with a
dedicated representative
chester currently is in rockingham
district four including auburn chester
and sandown
which have
4953 4786
and
5986 citizens respectively
that's 15 0707 in total
five representatives are elected to
serve all three towns collectively since
each town has more than 3 44 citizens
required for dedicated representative
we hope it would be possible and in
compliance with the constitution to do
so
with respect to chester
as others have noted about their town
we are a unique community
bound together by where we live and our
common interest in supporting our
friends and neighbors
and the chester way of life
far more than we are bound to any
particular political party
we have long history and traditions next
year chester would celebrate its 300th
anniversary
and we work very much together as
citizens and volunteers whether to
preserve our historic leading house
from the 1700s support the quality of
our schools our roads and bridges our
conservation land the quality of our
water
but also we work together to keep our
property taxes as low as we can
these are largest expenditures for most
of our residents
our state representatives and the
decisions of the general court and the
state government as a whole have
significant impact on the services and
funding we receive each year to ensure
our quality of life and determine how
much our property taxes increase or
decrease
the fact that this is largely controlled
significantly controlled by the state
and not the town is what we call in
chester the new hampshire disadvantage
it is important to have a dedicated
representative who is always focused on
the impact votes and decisions of
concord will have on our chester
priorities and our local taxes
a dedicated representative from the
chester community will also be able to
focus
just on the citizens of chester the 4
700 rather than more than 15 000
gene sharon who was one of our former
state representatives
spoke
at our town meeting about his experience
trying to represent the district
he noted that representatives perform a
lot of work that people don't see
for individual constituents it's very
important but it's also very time
consuming
he noted that chester qualified some
years ago for a single representative
and that when he served it was a stretch
for him to serve all the representatives
across the three towns
he noted the chester community needs a
representative who will have the time
and the interest in the town
to answer people's phone calls
and return them and act on their behalf
i expect the residents of auburn and
sandown and other towns without
dedicated representatives feel the way
people in chesterfield each town is
unique
we are focused in new hampshire on the
community in which we live not on the
state
or not on the national politics
it's the community where we will where
we live and we will benefit from a
dedicated representative to help in the
state house to promote our views and
hold the state government accountable
for taking actions to help control our
local property taxes
along with the other citizens of
rockhampton county i'll look forward to
the opportunity to review and comment on
the redistrict proposal from your
committee when it is complete
and i hope you will decide to provide
dedicated representatives for chester
and other qualified towns
i thank you for this opportunity
and uh
appreciate your consideration thank you
thank you
believe i have someone else from chester
here to speak on i just copied your name
down dara theodos
not even close
[Music]
dana theogus from chester thank you
obviously my penmanship is also poor
[Music]
i appreciate um
elected representatives where it is a
professional job with a volunteer
salary and each of the volunteers here
are
responsible to their own community
when i look around i see a specific
demographic
on where you are but also behind me
where people myself like myself and
younger are not represented here
and that is a large part because of the
responsibilities that we have that are
pulling us in different directions
however covid and emergency rulings
allowed in our community for online
meetings and that allowed for increased
participation and i would ask that this
committee consider
a more inclusive opportunity for a more
diverse
group to speak to you
in chester
we have a small community a very active
community and we meet our
representatives at town fair
at the transfer station
at election day this is an opportunity
for us to speak directly to our
representatives
and if we do not have someone in our
exact community we don't have direct
representation and that is something
that as a new hampshire resident we
should have
i also do really look forward to the
opportunity after the master john to
have a second public comment
to discuss the reasons that you've
chosen to
place the communities together
thank you
thank you for letting me know
christy saint laurent
good evening my name is christy st
laurent i'm from the town of windham i'd
like to thank the committee for getting
the opportunity for people to share our
thoughts with you as you are entering
into this process
um
the
the town of wingham did pass a warrant
article
where the majority vast majority of the
town
requested that this committee would go
through this process in a fair and
transparent manner and in a way that is
respectful of
not just the geographical divides but
or geographical locations but also many
varied interest groups that make new
hampshire such a great place to live
i would like to speak up to
requests that you do acknowledge and
make possible for each town that is
eligible to have his own state
representatives um windham and the last
redistricting were separated from salem
and when you look at them population
wise when him was very much dwarfed and
continues to be very much dwarfed by
our next door neighbor
and by having your own representatives
from your own town you get the
opportunity to rub elbows with them as
we said at the transfer station at the
grocery store local restaurants
and it really provides a two-way street
of information a lot of people um
believe it or not don't sit and watch
all the broadcasts of every committee
meeting
but it gives the opportunity um to say
hey what's going on in concord and how
does that relate to to windham as well
as if there is something that you want
to speak up about a lot of people
um although you guys are all very nice
are hesitant to go speak publicly
but it does give them that opportunity
when they see the representatives around
town to be able to give that input
and so that that
two-way street kind of works its way up
the ladder as well for the state summit
districts for the executive council
districts and as was mentioned um
executive council district 2 is crazy
um you know if you look at the way it
goes all the way across the state very
diverse regions that it represents and
very very different
issues that the different areas of the
state are going through i can't even
imagine trying to wrap my head around
all of the issues across that whole that
whole district
so i would
respectfully request as you go through
this process
that you do recognize the number of
towns in new hampshire that did pass the
warrant articles and in that way spoke
to directly to you
and the rest of the legislature in
[Music]
redistricting in a way that is fair and
transparent reflective of our state and
our demographics and without
gerrymandering
i would also like to ask too that in
this process that the maps are made
available both to the
legislature that's going to be voting on
them but also to the public with enough
time for careful consideration before
the votes are made so that further input
can be made
and thank you for your time
thank you
also signed up to speak
from greenland
and a passer
hello my name is alice passer i'm a
physician i live in greenland thank you
very much for the opportunity to address
address the group
i simply want to say that
i hope that you take your job seriously
as far as free and fair redistricting
according
according to the state constitution i
also would like to
echo what other speakers have said about
the importance of transparency and
giving the public a chance to see what
you've created after you've done so to
review and comment thank you very much
thank you for those comments
uh
also signed up to speak i have trish kit
from kingston
[Music]
hello
i'm king i'm trish ted i am a lifelong
resident of kingston
um just a couple of things on the
numbers um kingston and hampstead are
grouped together as our district
um we are not equal
kingston is actually smaller than
hampstead but quite a bit uh yesterday
about one third larger
so
our representatives having an agreement
between themselves
to have two from each town actually does
the town of hampstead disservice because
if we just went on the votes they would
have more of the same than kingston does
so unlike what what the representative
claimed
there also is no way to guarantee equal
representation
it's just an agreement between
the current floor reps that we have
um
i ask that both of our towns do qualify
for our own representative
our two towns they have
very different needs and concerns
they're part of different school
districts they don't have a whole lot in
common
beyond that and like one of the other
people said we don't share any
public facilities or anything like that
um both towns do qualify
um and they both qualified in 2010 as
well so we have a history of having that
population
thank
thank you for speaking
maureen
delakian from salem
oh
so so what happened is you signed up you
said yes or no if you wanted to speak
and i'm going through the question marks
now
phyllis snacky from
new fans it looks like
thank you very much yes i was a
question mark
um
thank you madam chairman thank you
representatives and senators
and i would also
like to say thank you to everyone here
because i think with
everything we've seen this week um
there have been
a number of examples of a lack of
civility
at
some hearings and political things and i
just want to say
i was a little worried coming here today
going oh is this going to be okay and i
just want to say thank you to everybody
here for being
professional and civil thank you
and
there have been so many people who have
spoken before me who are much more
eloquent than i and i would just like to
echo
that i too
support um having a non-partisan
independent
body to help with distributing
to make it fair transparent and without
gerrymandering and i too
um
would like future hearings to have a
remote option
and um additional public hearings after
the maps are withdrawn
thank you very much thank you thank you
for making it be nice
uh
victor helenelle
victor hello guys
thank you for coming out today and
taking time i'm sure you've all got
day jobs and responsibilities and here's
gotta get another job representing us
here at united states
i'm from salem
and uh
my point just getting getting up to
speak is uh
that i believe in voting i'm uh i am the
the validator in one of the districts
and uh
for the last three elections the primary
general event of the town
um and i fall and volunteered for that
because i have firmly believed in voting
as one of the things that we can do as
americans and i've always believed in
that from as a child now here in uh
i've been uh given a chance to
participate in that
so that's the one thing uh
as i mentioned i believe in but it is
our country has so very little of us
we have to pay taxes
and they ask that we vote
and uh everything else is pretty much
voluntary at it after that and um and
because i believe in voting we need to
make sure that voting remains desirable
a function to do something that you want
to contribute to and uh and as part of
the part of the redistrict as part of
the redistricting effort here
hopefully that can bring more people in
and
know that their votes do actually count
because it is one of the fundamental
tenets that makes our country so much
different than others around the world
so
and there's been many others that have
spoken for me here with wonderful points
uh all of them i and i can't add
to that but this is a bigger broader
brighter picture about the importance of
general voting in our collective
responsibility and really i thank you
all for
taking the time out of your lives um to
do this for for us to
represent us in this
madam chair chair with the red
representatives
appreciate your time tonight thank you
thank you for coming and speaking
i also have a kevin
krumlos
[Music]
good evening folks uh
members of the committee appreciate your
work tonight my name is kevin fleming i
live in exeter but i've been teaching
government and history for a number of
years in hampton
and i'd like to go back and
recall or release knowledge you've had a
number of thoughtful
comments and observations tonight
but i'd like to go back to the notion
maybe in the historical context of
gerrymandering
there is
a
cynicism may i sadly tell you
that is in the younger generation that
speaks to the notion that money
and partisan politics have poisoned the
elections and the governing
and on that basis
may i respectfully request that in your
work
you avoid any
and all accusation that generating is
continuing
that is the signal that tells folks
that things are not fair
so we'd like to ask you to be attentive
to that to be concerned with that as you
probably well are but to be strong and
to be fair
and to avoid any accusations thank you
thank you for your comments also signed
up to speak tonight with representative
deborah offshore
thank you good evening
and uh thank you all for dedicating
your time and talents to our state your
efforts to be here in rockingham county
tonight i know some of you have traveled
a great distance
are much appreciated
i'll start by saying that these public
hearings
should be accessible to those who cannot
attend in person
and the public needs the ability to
testify remotely via reassumed
had that opportunity been afforded
tonight i would be testifying via zoom
i understand this might not have been
the decision of the committee and lies
within the purview of the speaker the
honorable sherman packard seeing as this
committee is chaired by and has a
majority of members from
the speaker's party i would urge you to
use that to your advantage and to our
advantage and encourage a more
accessible hearing format
eight days ago here in rockingham county
the county convention met in person like
this
without a remote option and similar to
tonight
many people have chosen not to wear
masks to mitigate the spread of covet
19. that night nearly 60 people the
majority elderly were exposed
there are members of the rockingham
county convention whose health is too
fragile to risk infection
and they should not be excluded from
participation
there are members of my community of
stratum who also express interest in
participation but are of fragile health
and though and they thought at least
they would be able to watch the live
stream but there isn't one tonight
in 2019
my town of stratham along with 30 other
towns that year
voted at our annual town meeting on a
warrant article stating that we support
and demand an independent redistricting
commission
that was an idea that was supported
statewide passed the house and the
senate only to be vetoed by the governor
last year there are many of you on this
committee commissioned tonight who voted
for that independent redistricting
commission
but we don't have that
and we find ourselves in the exact
position we had all worked so
strenuously to avoid a partisan process
but we must embrace this process with an
eye on fairness
in our map drawing and to avoid the
siren song of people who crow about
redrawing the maps to give their party a
geographical advantage
on behalf of the voters of stratum i
respectfully ask this committee to
consider the following
as voters and citizens we have common
interests with our neighbors
particularly with school districts
and public services where they are
shared
we ask that the maps reflect that and
not break up school districts over
multiple voting districts and that they
be grouped together to mirror our
communities
we understand that according we
understand in stratham that according to
the latest census data we will be
allotted our two representatives
and have representation most likely with
another plotarial representative
we ask that that remain within our
school district
here in rockingham county there have
been changes
in populations to the towns of
nottingham deerfield
candia auburn chester atkinson plaistow
hampstead sandown kingston
new market seabrook greenland and rye
they should each have their own
dedicated districts in this round
we ask that a correction to the
executive council map be executed by
this committee
the district 2 as it is known the dragon
district is nothing short of ridiculous
and cynically drawn in its geographical
scope
it is a poor reflection on us as a state
that it was gerrymandered in that way
and we can do better
why the cities of rochester somersworth
dover and the towns of durham madbury
and rollinsburg are not in our district
is a 10 year old mystery perhaps this
committee can solve that
we ask that the congressional map be
reflective of the competitiveness
that the maps have now
there have been only nominal changes in
the populations of those current
districts and there should not be any
drastic changes like the often bandied
about idea
of the rumored carving out of manchester
and allotting it to district 2. that
would be unacceptable
and as for transparency the public needs
more notice for these public meetings
and as i mentioned at the beginning they
need to be accessible to everyone
and finally
the minute the map
the draft maps are finished
we need to have digital digital
accessibility the public needs digital
accessibility to those draft maps
and we ask you to please come back here
to wonderful rockingham county
for another round of statewide meetings
to repeat
an opportunity for the public to put
input into your work product
i really thank you for your time and
dedication to this laborious task that
will either produce manipulative maps
that reflect the ideologies of a
singular party
or
fair maps
fair maps that reflect the true new
hampshire in the fairest way we can be
thank you i'll email my testimony to you
thank you
is there anyone else here tonight who
would like to speak thank you
i want to thank you all for coming to
redwood so that we have a chance to
speak to you tonight
for the purpose of being quick
two points i'd like to do this thanks
today tonight
it seems to me
that having a representative in your
town if you have the population is one
of the key things
in terms of having
a real opportunity to have someone speak
just before your deal when they have the
population that is constitutionally
meaningless requirements
but do we hope that you will do that the
second thing is
i don't know how maybe written something
but you know the first round
could only do a good set of eyes to look
at it
so
let people see that first draft
and get that feedback
because
we've heard a lot about gerrymandering
if we're really addressing that issue
we're being fair
then that first draft
on a sail way
thank you
is there anyone else who'd like to speak
i see a couple of hands i i believe you
spoke earlier let me recognize the woman
in the battle who i don't think has
spoken before then the
hi good evening
my name is catherine haraki um i live in
hampton
i'm sorry could you give us your name
again katherine rocky i live in hampton
i had to write this down as
congressional district 1 senate district
24 house district 21 executive council
district 3. so um
quickly when i ran for office for the
first time last spring i had to call the
state i had to call the secretary of
state and ask do i really have to put my
street address my personal address on
all my um on all my signs that i put on
the public i thought that was kind of
made me a little uncomfortable and the
secretary told me well that is the
regulation um it's from a remnant
in time
when we expected our constituents to
come to our front porch and talk about
issues
so um
the front approach is no longer
uh the main source of communication
between elect between you and your
constituents and um neither should a
close one like this
so i think please when you go ahead and
talk about the next steps keep in mind
what are you doing
are you doing it because it's a remnant
of something in the past
and what is your real goal
and we have a lot of tools we have
telephones we have zoom we have email we
have two-way communication lots of other
options besides front porches
and that's all i have to say thank you
um so i
got involved with this sort of as i'm an
independent voter uh worried about
where democracy is going and you've
heard all the stuff but i think the main
points i wanted to make but my main
thing was
how much i learned working with open
democracy on trying to draw some maps
that looked fair
and how much the devil's in the details
and
i felt that was a pretty educated voter
and then i realized how much i wasn't
and i think that's all the more reason
why it's going to be really important
that when these maps are drawn
initially they are shown to people
and someone explained it as much as they
can to me the most important thing
is that the districts are competitive
at the congressional level the executive
council
all those and to be honest the 2010s
actually had that fairly competitive
across the board that's something i
certainly want to see maintain
and i think the more this can be out
there and shown to the public and i
appreciate having this listening session
i think that's going to help new
hampshire voters stay involved and i
hope that you'll strongly consider
having the maps once they're
preliminarily drawn for at least some
type of comment i know it's a lot of
time energy and resources
to do it again but i think
it may help get more people involved
which is what we need to do so thanks
for your time
thank you for your comments
are there other persons here tonight yes
ma'am i'm sorry come on
i'm kay galloway i'm from atkinson which
is rockingham county district 14 which
is comprised of atkinson and plasto
i do note that representative noah major
is seated behind me but i think he will
agree that each of our towns is
deserving of its own representative
each of our towns is right about 7 000
residents and we have about 500 voters
in each town
i add my
voice to those who have echoed it loud
and clear that we need
independent districts if we've met the
criteria thank you for your time
thank you for
adding that
is there anybody else today
so
i also want to thank you all for being
here um eric burr from redwood
house and the um district
i guess my point and maybe it sounds a
little technical but um
that i totally agree with the idea
better put forth about keeping school
districts together about trying to keep
demographics and other groups aligned as
possible
um you know while balancing the equal
representation um
and i also agree that it's almost
impossible to know what makes town
similar
um i guess my one thought would be and
uh i my working world use gis a lot i
assume that'll be a gis based project
that underlies this process
um
rather than making the maps themselves
the final results
available i think it would be great if
you could make the
underlying data that's going into these
all the elements that are being
considered available to people in a
format that they can look at
and uh
you know
come to their own conclusions based on
the same elements that that you're going
to consider
in the end and then in the end um that
the districts that are created
um to the degree that it's possible
reflect all those aggregated statistics
that went into it so people can see the
end result and so
the feedback that they give which again
i also agree the second round would
break
um
that that feedback can be based on the
same elements that you're working on
thank you
anybody else here chad
vancouver
excuse me thank you i just thought of
one more thing if you just want to say
your name again
virginia thanks from canada
um i was just thinking as the last
person spoke of how confusing it is when
you try to align and look at the
districts that you're in for
representative and senate and executive
council and the confusing ways that they
don't overlap
so
i know that that's more
it's a very complex issue but to the
extent that they could align better that
would really help when
just trying to look at elections as a
whole
um and
that's enough thanks
anyone else
well if that's the case let the record
reflect that you have a rockingham
county elected official who has actually
declined to come to the mic at a
publication
and that in itself is somewhat
astonishing oh now
now he took the bait and here he comes
i believe that this is the chair
of the rockingham county delegation as
i'm correct as well as the chair of the
ways and means committee and a very long
time
distinguished member of the new
hampshire house
well thank you for that that might be
but we're still on the record so you
need to tell us who you are my name is
representative norman major i represent
the town of atkinson foster thank you
and i also as chairman of the county
delegation i came here tonight
to listen to the testimony
and from what i heard
this great testimony
and then
a constituent of mine from atkinson
okay i agree wholeheartedly with her
that we need to make as many single
districts as we can
so these communities get their
representation and they're not swamped
and
robbed of their
representation by a large community that
they may put with
thank you
[Music]
teaming up there
anybody else here tonight
all right i want to thank you all for
coming but before we close up i want to
make a couple of announcements first of
all this meeting was live streamed
and it was working the entire meeting
that was verified i don't need to be
rude when i was looking at my phone but
i'm doing various things which include
making sure that things are working
because you might suspect that sometimes
we have technical difficulties
and we need to be aware for this you
also heard a lot tonight that people
want
uh remote access well the reality is you
have remote access to the committee
members um all of you here or people at
home there are websites at the new
hampshire general court page
on the home page for the general court
there is a direct link to both the
senate redistricting committee and the
house redistricting committee if you
choose to go to the various chambers the
senator the house
we are on the house side the special
committee on redistricting and on the
senate side here senator gray what is
your official title
uh for the registering
senate special committee on
resistance the person who set it up
so there are links on the committee
sites to each of those committees
this is the process you would use to
look up any committee
and its business at the state house on
the house side once you get to the
special committee on redistricting you
will get various links there that will
allow you to look at the materials we've
been provided at committee meetings
watch our meetings which are online from
youtube recordings for you to be able to
see it you will have a link for you to
email all members of the committee it
will have a link for you to submit
testimony it has a link for you to
submit suggested maps um
and you can look and see what people
have submitted there are some maps up
there right now that people have
submitted for consideration for the
committee
so
um and you will be able to look there
tomorrow actually to see the video of
tonight's meeting
so we are trying to provide as much
remote access
as possible and i want to thank you all
for coming out tonight
we certainly appreciate your comments
and your appreciation and your
participation in this and appreciate it
greatly and drive safely have a have a
good rest of your evening representative
weber
thank you very much madam chair
um i have only one question which is i
know that our schedule has been somewhat
uh disruptive but do you have any idea
why we will actually have maps for
people to look at
there's nothing scheduled right now on
that and i as a matter of fact was
hoping to hear last week at our meeting
that people were working on maps and
when they were going to be done and i
didn't hear from anybody but we'll be
working on that schedule thank you and
thank you everybody for coming tonight
uh before the before the senate closes
their hearing i can't talk to the
committee members individually because
of rsa 91a and i just wanted to to the
senate members
that if you look at the maps that were
provided by mapathon
that
they make a significant change in
manchester into two districts
instead of the sharing of the outside
communities because i think manchester
comes in very close to the ideal number
breaking it into two they also break
nashua into three districts
uh because i believe that you can't
really do nashua
and get within the right
is percentages your plus seven if you
you do that and then
down into the executive council one
um
they list it as a
pro
that
manchester
nashua and concord
are all in separate districts where i
would think that they would be
communities of interest
so our first meeting that's a couple of
the first things that we will take up
uh and we'll schedule those meetings as
soon after we finish
the hearings if one of them like belnap
or whatever hangs out we may actually
have a meeting before that but again
just senate business so
that i've done it in public so
i don't violate rsa 91as
all right thank you
thank you everybody